This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Think about the last time you were part of a brainstorming session. We just need to brainstorm, five ideas. But to be safe, let's come up with 50. Let's make it 100. Maybe this was at work, or at a planning meeting for a community organization. Just when I emphasized there's no bad ideas here, we're just brainstorming. Many people probably suggested ideas,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹特姆。回想一下你最近一次参加头脑风暴会议的情形。我们只需要头脑风暴，提出五个点子。但为了稳妥起见，我们还是想50个吧。干脆100个吧。也许是在工作中，或者是在社区组织的规划会议上。就在我强调这里没有烂点子，我们只是在头脑风暴的时候。许多人可能提出了各种想法，
perhaps there was some discussion about which proposal was best. At the end, maybe everyone voted on the best idea. If your meeting was like most meetings, there was probably one kind of idea that was in short supply. How to do less. I remember a brainstorming session some years ago where colleagues filled an entire wall with posted notes.
也许大家还讨论了哪个方案最好。最后，可能所有人投票选出了最佳方案。如果你的会议和大多数会议一样，有一种想法大概是严重短缺的。那就是如何做到“做更少的事”。我记得几年前的一次头脑风暴会议，同事们在整面墙上贴满了便利贴。
When I looked at the posted wall later on, I was struck that almost none of the notes suggested that the organization could streamline projects or stop doing things that weren't working. All the ideas were about expansion, new projects. Today we ask why we often ignore one of the most powerful paths to innovation. When less is more, this week on Hidden Brain. Humans are curious and inventive creatures.
后来当我看着这面贴满便利贴的墙时，我震惊地发现，几乎没有一张便条建议组织可以简化项目或停止那些行不通的事情。所有的想法都围绕着扩张和新项目。今天，我们来探讨为什么我们常常忽视通往创新的最强大途径之一。当“少即是多”时，本周收听《隐藏的大脑》。人类是充满好奇心和创造力的生物。
Give us a problem and we will come up with solutions. Usually, this is a marvelous skill. Our drive to invent new things, generate new ideas, is responsible for great breakthroughs in science, technology and medicine. There are times, however, when I desire to come up with new solutions, gets in the way of coming up with the best solutions. At the University of Virginia, LIDY CLOTS has long been fascinated by the process of invention and an important component of invention that many of us overlook.
给我们一个问题，我们就会想出解决方案。通常，这是一项了不起的技能。我们发明新事物、产生新想法的驱动力，造就了科学、技术和医学领域的伟大突破。然而，有时我渴望提出新解决方案的愿望，反而妨碍了我们提出最佳解决方案。在弗吉尼亚州立大学，利迪·克洛茨长期以来一直着迷于发明创造的过程，以及我们许多人忽视的发明的一个重要组成部分。
LIDY CLOTS, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks, Shankar. It's great to be here. Lighty, when you were an undergraduate trying to master the fundamentals of engineering, you initially adopted an approach to studying that will be familiar to many students. What was that approach? And how did it work out for you in your college course on mechanics? Yeah, so for those of listeners that have enough sense not to major in engineering mechanics is this branch of physics that deals with objects at rest and in motion. And it requires you to go from plugging numbers
利迪·克洛茨，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，香卡。很高兴来到这里。利迪，当你还是个试图掌握工程学基础知识的本科生时，你最初采用了一种许多学生都会熟悉的学习方法。那是什么方法？它在你的大学力学课上效果如何？是的，所以对于那些有足够理智没有主修工程学的听众来说，力学是物理学的一个分支，研究静止和运动中的物体。它要求你从将数字代入
into equations to actually visualizing how the concepts work in the world. And my approach to mechanics was the approach that I've been using in all my courses up to that point, which was, okay, figure out how to solve the problems that I've been assigned for homework, learn that specific problem, and try to cram as many of those into my brain as possible, so that when the exam came about,
方程式，转变为实际想象这些概念在现实世界中是如何运作的。我对力学的学习方法，是我在那之前所有课程中一直在用的方法，那就是：好吧，弄清楚如何解决分配给我的家庭作业题目，学会那个特定问题，并试图把尽可能多的这种问题塞进我的大脑，这样当考试到来时，
I'd be more likely to have an exact replica of the problem that was on the exam already accessible in my brain. And how were you doing in terms of grades as the semester unfolded? I had a sea average. So I was coming and it was serious. I mean I was coming into the third exam with the sea average. And for the first time in my life I was in danger of failing the course. And if that happened I would either have to delay my degree progress and ask my parents
我更有可能在我的大脑中已经存有考试中那道题的精确复制品。随着学期的展开，你的成绩情况如何？我的平均分是C。所以我当时……情况很严重。我是说，我带着C的平均分迎来了第三次考试。我这辈子第一次面临不及格的危险。如果真的发生那样的事，我要么不得不延误学位进度，并要求我父母
to pay extra tuition to take the course the following year or change my major to something that didn't require me to pass mechanics. So at one point as you were getting these bad grades, you came up with a radical and some might say risky approach for the final portion of the semester. What did you do, Lighty? I just really stripped away the extraneous things that I was trying to cram into my brain. And this first mechanics class really just boils down to applying Newton's second law of motion. So all of these scenarios can be described
支付额外的学费以便在第二年重修这门课，要么就得转专业，转到一个不需要通过力学考试的专业。因此，在某个时刻，当你拿到这些差劲的成绩时，你为这学期的最后阶段想出一个激进的、甚至有人可能会说是冒险的方法。你做了什么，利迪？我只是真正剥离了我试图塞进大脑的那些无关紧要的东西。这门初级力学课实际上归根结底就是应用牛顿第二运动定律。所以所有这些情景都可以用
by force equals mass times acceleration. And I could derive everything I needed from that equation. And so before that third exam, I stopped memorizing dozens of other equations and tangential ideas. I didn't need to know a bunch of forces and masses and accelerations. I just needed to remember that formula f equals mA. So you try this radical approach.
力等于质量乘以加速度来描述。我只需要从那个方程式推导我需要的一切。所以在第三次考试之前，我停止死记硬背几十个其他方程和边缘概念。我不需要知道一堆力、质量和加速度。我只需要记住那个公式：F等于ma。所以你尝试了这个激进的方法。
You do the exam. And the day comes when the professor is handing out the grades. Paint me a picture of what happens. I'll never forget it. I mean, this is Professor Viscomi, just a classic, nice engineering professor, but he had this thing where when he handed the exams back, he would write the highest and lowest score on the chalkboard to give you a sense of kind of how the rest of the class did. And so this exam he comes in and he writes on the board a 98 and a 47. And then he looked at me and smirked.
你参加了考试。教授发成绩的日子到了。给我描绘一下当时的情景吧。我永远不会忘记。我是说，那是维斯科米教授，一个非常经典、善良的工程学教授，但他有一个习惯，当他发回试卷时，他会在黑板上写下最高分和最低分，让你对全班其他人的表现有个大致了解。所以这次考试他走进来，在黑板上写下98分和47分。然后他看着我，露出了诡秘的微笑。
And everybody assumed that I had gotten the 47. My classmates were playfully, you know, cheering me. And I'm sitting there thinking about like, okay, now that I've failed out of engineering, what will my major be? And when I got my test back, I realized why he had smirked. thinking about like, okay, now that I've failed out of engineering, what will my major be? And when I got my test back, I realized why he had smirked and it was because I had earned the 98.
每个人都以为我得了47分。我的同学们开玩笑似地为我……你知道的，为我起哄。而我坐在那里心想：好吧，既然我已经被工程专业淘汰了，我的专业会是什么？当我拿回试卷时，我才明白他为什么会露出诡秘的微笑。心想：好吧，既然我已经被工程专业淘汰了，我的专业会是什么？当我拿回试卷时，我才明白他为什么会露出诡秘的微笑，那是因为我得了98分。
Lidy did better when he focused his mind on fewer things, on core concepts. And it was a start of a long journey to recognize the value in everyday life of removing, of reducing, of subtraction. Some years later, after lightly graduated, got married and started a family, he had another moment of insight. He was building a bridge using Legos with his son Ezra. He was three at the time and we were building a bridge out of his duplow blocks, the bigger legos, and the support towers were different heights, so we couldn't
当利迪将注意力集中在更少的事情和核心概念上时，他考得更好。这是一段漫长旅程的开始，让他认识到在日常生活中进行移除、减少和做减法的价值。几年后，利迪毕业、结婚并组建家庭后，他有了另一次顿悟。当时他和三岁的儿子以斯拉正在用乐高积木搭建一座桥。他当时三岁，我们在用他的得宝积木（也就是大号的乐高积木）搭一座桥，支撑塔的高度不同，所以我们无法
span them, they weren't level. And as I turned back toward the soon-to-be bridge, Ezra had already removed a block from the taller tower, so whereas my impulse had been to add to the short support in that moment, I realized that it wasn't the only way to create a level bridge. So this moment captured in a concrete way for you, how many of us underestimate the power of subtraction. And I understand you showed other people a replica of Ezra's bridge to see how many of them came up
跨越它们，它们不在同一水平面上。当我转过身去面对这座即将建成的桥时，以斯拉已经从较高的塔上拿走了一块积木，所以，虽然我当时的冲动是给矮的支撑物加高，但在那一刻我意识到，这并不是打造水平桥梁的唯一方法。所以这一刻以具体的方式向你捕捉到了，我们当中有多少人低估了做减法的力量。据我了解，你向其他人展示了以斯拉桥梁的复制品，看看有多少人想到了
with the idea of taking away a block instead of adding a block. Yeah, students would come to talk to me about their assignments and I'd give them this bridge and see what they did and everybody added like me. And then I also took it to Gabe Adams who's a professor, colleague of mine. And I thought that I had been talking to her
拿走一块积木而不是加上一块积木的主意。是的，学生们会来找我谈论他们的作业，我会把这座桥给他们看，看看他们做了什么，结果每个人都像我一样往上加。然后我也把它拿给盖布·亚当斯看，她是一位教授，也是我的同事。我想我一直都在和她讨论这些想法，而且她还是个天才。所以我想，好吧，当我把这个给她时，她肯定会做减法。
about these ideas and plus she's like a genius. So I figured, okay, she's the one who's going to subtract here when I give her this. And so I give it to her and she added like me. But then when I said, hey, this is what Ezra did, she says, oh, oh, oh, so what you've been trying to say is that you're interested in why do we overlook subtraction as a way to improve things?
于是我把它交给了她，结果她也像我一样往上加。但随后当我告诉她：“嘿，这是以斯拉做的”时，她说：“哦，哦，哦，所以你一直想说的是，你对为什么我们忽视了将减法作为改善事物的方法很感兴趣？”
So, so Lidy, you became obsessed with the value of subtraction. Some might even say you became a zealot. You started collecting examples from the worlds of engineering and design, and you stumbled in the work of the early 20th century architect Anna Kijklein. Tell me her story. Oh, she's a fascinating person. She was the first female licensed architect in the state of Pennsylvania. She played basketball in college, was one was the first female licensed architect in the state of Pennsylvania. She played basketball in college,
所以，利迪，你对做减法的价值着迷了。有些人甚至可能会说你成了一个狂热分子。你开始从工程学和设计界收集例子，并且偶然发现了20世纪初建筑师安娜·基克莱因的作品。跟我讲讲她的故事吧。哦，她是个迷人的人物。她是宾夕法尼亚州第一位获得执照的女建筑师。她上大学时打过篮球，是宾夕法尼亚州第一位获得执照的女建筑师。她上大学时打过篮球，
was one of the first women to drive a car. She was also a serial inventor. And she made one of the most ingenious advances of the 20th century. And before Anna Kijklein, building blocks were solid. So if your house is more than a century old, it probably rests on solid blocks. In her patent, and I think this was 1927, Kijklein invented the K brick which started to subtract some of the mass
是第一批开车的主妇之一。她也是一位连续发明家。她取得了20世纪最具创意的进展之一。在安娜·基克莱因之前，建筑积木都是实心的。所以如果你的房子有一百多年的历史，它可能就是建立在实心砖上的。在她的专利中，我想这是1927年，基克莱因发明了K型砖，开始从建筑积木中减去一些质量。
from building blocks. What she essentially did was create a hollow block, knowing that the load bearing could happen on the outside parts of the block. And by creating the hollow block you remove half the material compared to what was in the typical building block, which of course makes it less expensive and easier to build with and less fuel to transport. And then these hollow blocks also provide more insulation because of the air voids that are in the blocks.
她本质上做的是创造了一种空心砖，因为她知道承重可以发生在积木的外侧部分。通过制造空心砖，与典型建筑砖块中的材料相比，你减少了一半的材料，这当然使它的成本更低、更容易建造，运输所需的燃料也更少。然后，由于积木内部有空气空隙，这些空心砖还提供更多的隔热性能。
So the resulting buildings are more comfortable, less nosy, less prone to fire, and the block itself is less expensive. And her subtractive insight, it's since gone through several evolutions, but it's led to this building block that's now ubiquitous. It's used to build everything
因此，由此产生的建筑物更舒适、噪音更小、更不易着火，并且砖块本身的成本也更低。她这种做减法的洞察力，此后经过了几次演变，但它催生了一种如今无处不在的建筑砖块。它被用来建造从
from the facades of schools and skyscrapers to the foundation walls for my two-story addition. Once we become familiar with a particular object, we tend to look for ways to add to it, rather than to subtract from it. But the act of taking away can produce remarkable results. One of LIDI's favorite examples is an invention known as the Strider bike. These are the pedal-less mini bikes that basically allow kids as soon as one and a half years old to ride a bike. And the way they work, they're small bikes, but they're not
学校和摩天大楼的立面，到我那两层扩展部分的基墙等一切东西。一旦我们熟悉了一个特定的物体，我们往往会寻找为它做加法的方法，而不是做减法。但拿走的举动可以产生显著的结果。利迪最喜欢的例子之一是一项被称为“滑步车”（Strider bike）的发明。这些是没有脚踏板的迷你自行车，基本上能让一岁半的孩子就骑上自行车。它们的工作原理是，它们是小型的自行车，但不是
propelled by chains and pedals, but by toddlers striding with their legs. That's why they're called strider bikes. And what happens is the toddler propels the bike forward, kind of like a Flintstone cars. And what's even more impressive is once my son is since aged out of the strider bike, and once he decided it was time for his big kid bike, we didn't have to bother with training wheels. He already knew how to balance, and he just needed to learn how to push the pedals and, of course, to break. And children's bikes were marketed as their own distinct class of bicycle for almost a century, and there were plenty of design changes over that time, right? Training wheels, fatter tires, more and more speeds, you know, those contraptions that connect a kid's bike to a grown-ups like a caboose. And it took a really long time for somebody to have the insight of, hey, will this be better if we subtract the pedals and the drivetrain?
靠链条和脚踏板驱动，而是由幼儿用双腿滑行前进。这就是为什么它们被称为滑步车。发生的情况是，幼儿推动自行车向前，有点像《摩登原始人》里的汽车。更令人印象深刻的是，一旦我儿子到了不再适合滑步车年龄的时候，当他决定是时候换大童自行车时，我们根本不用费心去安装辅助轮。他已经知道如何保持平衡，他只需要学会如何踩踏板，当然还有如何刹车。儿童自行车作为一种独特的自行车类别被推销了近一个世纪，在那期间有大量的设计变更，对吧？辅助轮、更胖的轮胎、越来越多的速度档，你知道的，那种把儿童自行车像挂车一样连接到大人自行车上的装置。花了很长时间才终于有人产生这样的灵感：“嘿，如果我们把脚踏板和传动系统减掉，这会更好吗？”
And when they did think of it, it made these two-wheeled bikes right-able for a whole new age group and saleable to their parents. So later you began to ask yourself after seeing these examples, how you could apply the insights of subtraction to your own life. And at one point, you came up with a novel approach to a home renovation project. You threw down an unusual challenge to your students. A design contest, you called it addition by subtraction. Can you describe the challenge to me? Sure. So we moved to University of Virginia and we downsized our home when we moved here. And the home had also been a student rental.
当他们想到这一点时，它使得这些两轮自行车适合了一个全新的年龄段，并且更容易卖给他们的父母。所以后来在看到这些例子后，你开始问自己，如何将做减法的见解应用到你自己的生活中。在某个时候，你对一个家居装修项目想出了一个新颖的方法。你向你的学生们提出了一个不同寻常的挑战。一个设计比赛，你称之为“通过减法实现加法”。你能向我描述一下这个挑战吗？当然。所以我们搬到了弗吉尼亚大学，搬来时我们把房子买小了。这栋房子以前也是学生出租房。
And so we knew that we were going to have to do a renovation. Subtraction was top of mind, and I'm an engineer slash architect, I guess, by profession. And so I was like, can we put subtraction into play here? And so the name of our contest was addition by subtraction, and I have the great fortune of working with really smart students for whom I ran a design contest.
所以我们知道我们必须进行翻新。减法是首要考虑的因素，而且我职业上算是一个工程师兼建筑师，我想。所以我就想：我们能在这里把减法付诸实践吗？因此，我们比赛的名字叫“通过减法实现加法”，我有幸与非常聪明的学生们合作，我为他们举办了一场设计比赛。
And we emphasized that our goal was to subtract. And we even said that we were willing to pay more if the renovation could make a statement through subtraction. And I offered $1,000 in cash and free cookies, and a couple of dozen architecture engineering and environmental design type majors signed up. But the, and the students came up with clever designs. There was one student who found unused vertical space
我们强调我们的目标是做减法。我们甚至说，如果翻新能够通过减法发表某种声明，我们愿意支付更多的费用。我提供了1000美元现金和免费饼干，几十个建筑、工程和环境设计专业的学生报了名。但是，这些学生想出了聪明的设计。有一个学生找到了我们房子里未被利用的垂直空间，
in our house and used that to add it a lofted area to Ezra's bedroom. There was a junior who changed the grading of our backyard and that provided outside access to the basement, which then turned that into a viable living space. And there is this graduate student team that kind of intricately reconfigured the entire floor plan. And all of those things would have made our house more livable. And yet no one had actually subtracted, right? Nobody had taken away square footage.
并用它给以斯拉的卧室加了一个阁楼区。还有一个大三学生改变了我们后院的坡度，从而提供了通往地下室的外部通道，然后把那里变成了一个宜居的生活空间。还有一个研究生团队，他们以复杂的方式重新配置了整个平面图。所有这些都会让我们的房子更宜居。然而，实际上没有人做减法，对吧？没有人拿走平方英尺。
Ladi, at the end of this whole process of invention, what was the end result of your home renovation project? My wife was worried you would ask. So, because now we have a five room two-story, 900 square foot addition that extends from the rear of what had been a little Cape Cod. Lighty's design contest ultimately failed as a generator of ideas that would lead to subtraction.
利迪，在这整个发明过程的最后，你家装修项目的最终结果是什么？我妻子担心你会这么问。所以，因为现在我们有了一个五房间、两层楼、900平方英尺的扩展部分，它是从原本一个小雪松顶住宅的后方延伸出去的。利迪的设计比赛最终作为产生减法想法的源泉失败了。
He discovered that while subtraction might be a powerful driver of invention, many powerful obstacles stand in its way. Understanding those obstacles and how to overcome them became his new obsession. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Lidy Klotz is an engineer at the University of Virginia. He studies our automatic tendency to add things when it comes to solving problems. After a home renovation project explicitly aimed at subtraction, ended up greatly expanding the size of his Cape Cod home,
他发现，虽然减法可能是发明的强大驱动力，但许多强大的障碍阻碍了它的发展。理解这些障碍以及如何克服它们成为了他的新痴迷。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹特姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹特姆。利迪·克洛茨是弗吉尼亚大学的一名工程师。他研究的是我们在解决问题时倾向于做加法的这种自动化倾向。在家居装修项目明确旨在做减法，最终却极大地扩大了他那栋雪松顶住宅的规模之后，
Lidy started to ask why human beings find it so hard to subtract. So Lidy, at the end of this home renovation project, Lighty started to ask why human beings find it so hard to subtract. So Lighty, at the end of this home renovation project, you were humbled by the process, but it also gave you some important insights into why it is so hard to subtract, to remove, to take away. When it comes to home renovations in particular, one barrier to subtraction was economics? Yeah, for us, I mean, this is the biggest investment our family has and the kind of rule of thumb for home's values, how Zillow calculates it, how the realtor's calculated when they're appraising it, is that the value increases with the total square footage.
利迪开始探究为什么人类会发现做减法如此困难。所以，利迪，在这个家居装修项目的最后，利迪开始探究为什么人类会发现做减法如此困难。所以，利迪，在这个家居装修项目的最后，这个过程让你感到谦卑，但也给你带来了一些重要的见解，让你明白为什么减法、移除、拿走是如此困难。特别是说到家居装修，阻碍减法的一个障碍是经济因素？是的，对我们来说，这是我们家最大的投资，房屋价值的经验法则——Zillow是如何计算的，房产经纪人在评估时是如何计算的——是价值随着总平方英尺的增加而增加。
So, you know, 2,000 square foot, that's one price. If you have 2,500 square feet, that's one price. If you have 2500 square feet, that's another price. And entrance in the design competition and Monika and I could just never figure out a way past this financial reality. I mean, spending money without adding square footage would have been a really risky investment and spending money to get rid of existing square footage was preposterous.
所以，你知道的，2000平方英尺是一个价格。如果你有2500平方英尺，那就是另一个价格。如果你有2500平方英尺，又是另一个价格。设计比赛的参赛者以及莫妮卡和我怎么也无法克服这个财务现实。我的意思是，在不增加平方英尺的情况下花钱将是一项非常冒险的投资，而花钱摆脱现有的平方英尺则是荒谬的。
Another thing was this was just, to get rid of existing square footage was preposterous. Another thing was this was just, it's not that subtracting is always the right option. We did, it has been beneficial to have more square footage in our home, our family was growing and we did need some more square footage. So this may have been a case where subtracting wasn't the better option, even though we started out with that is our intention.
另一件事是，这仅仅是……并不是说做减法永远是正确的选择。我们确实……拥有更多平方英尺的房子对我们是有利的，我们的家庭在扩大，我们确实需要更多的平方英尺。所以这可能是一个减法并非更好选择的案例，尽管我们最初的意图确实是做减法。
And also thinking that presumably there were people, architects and builders and contractors, and they all get paid more for doing more, not for doing less. Exactly. If we had hired a contractor to subtract space, they're getting paid based on the percentage of how much it costs them to do the renovation. And if so, a less expensive renovation that's subtract space, they get less overhead on that. I'm also thinking that, you know, expanding during a home renovation is also what sort of culturally expected, right? I mean, how many people do a renovation and end up with a smaller home? Well, I mean, it's right there in the word, right? I mean, the many people do a renovation and end up with a smaller home? Well, I mean, it's right there in the word, right? I mean, the synonym for home renovation is a home addition.
而且还想到，据推测有很多人——建筑师、建筑商和承包商，他们都是因为做得多而获得更多报酬，而不是因为做得少。完全正确。如果我们雇佣了一个承包商来减少空间，他们获得的报酬是基于他们完成装修成本的百分比。如果是一个减少空间的成本较低的装修，他们在其中的管理费就更少了。我也在想，你知道的，在家居装修期间进行扩张也是文化上所期望的，对吧？我的意思是，有多少人在装修后房子反而变小了？嗯，我的意思是，这个词本身就说明了一切，对吧？我的意思是，家居装修的同义词就是家居扩建。
You never hear of a home subtraction. Yeah. So, as you started to think about the economic and cultural obstacles to practicing subtraction, you came to understand that such obstacles reach very far back into human history. How so, Lady? Certainly, in human history, let's start there. That's this concept of monumental architecture. And again, on my background's engineering, I like big structures. I was surprised to learn about how key a role people think, or the scientists think monumental architecture played in the development
你从来没听说过家居缩减。是的。所以，当你开始思考实践减法的经济和文化障碍时，你开始明白这种障碍深深植根于人类历史之中。怎么说，利迪？当然，在人类历史上，让我们从那里开始。这就是宏伟建筑的概念。再次说明，我的背景是工程学，我喜欢大型结构。我很惊讶地了解到，人们认为——或者科学家认为——宏伟建筑在人类发展中发挥了多么关键的作用。
of civilization. What do you mean by monumental architecture? It's literally defined by the fact that it adds well beyond what is necessary. So the principle defining feature of monumental architecture is that the scale and, you know, elaboration and detail exceed the requirements of any practical functions. So the Ziggarats and Mesopotamia, the pyramids of Egypt and China, these massive, but marginally useful structures kind of grew at the same time as the cities around them. And even today, you could argue that in a modern world, people are rewarded in terms of resources and status when they add as opposed to when they subtract.
文明的演进。你所说的宏伟建筑是什么意思？它的字面定义就是它远远超出了必要的程度。因此，宏伟建筑的主要定义特征是其规模、阐述和细节超出了任何实际功能的要求。因此，美索不达米亚的通天塔、埃及和中国的金字塔，这些庞大但用处有限的结构，与它们周围的城市同时发展壮大。即使在今天，你也可以认为，在现代社会中，当人们做加法而不是做减法时，他们会在资源和地位上得到回报。
We have markers and plaques for the people who build skyscrapers, not for the people who take them down. Exactly. That's a huge challenge on university campuses. For example, it's so much easier to get a donation for somebody to create a building that has their family's name on it than to a donation for removing
我们为建造摩天大楼的人树立纪念碑和牌匾，而不是为那些拆除它们的人。完全正确。这在大学校园里是一个巨大的挑战。例如，要想为建造一座刻有其家族姓氏的建筑获得捐赠要容易得多，而要为移除某些东西筹集捐赠，甚至为某种
something or for even for something that doesn't that has their family's name on it, then to a donation for removing something or for even for something that doesn't come with this big physical reminder of the person's generosity. It makes sense that donors want to put their money behind something tangible. Politicians similarly want to be able to cut a ribbon to tout a new amenity that they're delivering for their constituents.
没有这种巨大物理纪念意义的东西筹集捐赠，则要难得多。捐赠者希望把钱投在有形的东西上，这情有可原。政治官员同样希望能够剪彩，以宣传他们为选民提供的新设施。
It's hard to cut a ribbon on an empty field. These are the sorts of cultural and political forces that subtly push us to favor addition over subtraction. Across all of these examples, I mean, the problem is that subtracting is more work. It's more mental work. It's more kind of steps as we're talking about it. And there's less to show for it. And so after you do all this extra work, you have less evidence because the thing that you've done is by definition disappeared. So I understand that your your employer, the University of Virginia, once asked for suggestions
要在空地上剪彩是很困难的。这些都是微妙地促使我们倾向于加法而非减法的文化和政治力量。在所有这些例子中，问题在于做减法需要更多的工作。它是更多的脑力劳动。正如我们所讨论的，它涉及更多步骤。而且成果更少。在你做了所有这些额外的工作之后，你得到的证据却更少了，因为你所做的事情根据定义已经消失了。所以我听说你的雇主弗吉尼亚大学曾经征求过建议，
on how the university could be improved and you ended up analyzing the recommendations that came in. What did you find, Ladi? Yeah, we had a new, latest strategic planning effort with a new president and it began as these tend to by soliciting ideas from students, faculty, staff, community, alumni members, donors, and all of them were basically offering their ideas for how to improve the university. We got our hands on the data and as expected,
关于如何改进大学，你最终分析了收到的建议。你发现了什么，利迪？是的，我们有一项由新校长领导的最新战略规划工作，它像往常一样，通过向学生、教职员工、社区、校友成员和捐赠者征求意见开始，他们基本上都提出了关于如何改进大学的想法。我们拿到了数据，正如预期的那样，
the adding was rampant. I mean, people wanted more study abroad grants, more mental health services, teller to international students, more housing options. There was a request for a new ice arena, and I didn't know we had an ice hockey team here, but I'm assuming that's progress, too. But the thing is, surely there was untapped potential because out of 750 ideas for changing the university, fewer than 10% suggested taking something away. Yeah. I want to turn my attention to what happens within organizations, you know, when we're
做加法的情况非常猖獗。我是说，人们想要更多的海外留学奖学金、更多的心理健康服务、针对国际学生的帮助、更多的住房选择。有人要求建一个新的冰球场，我不知道我们这里有冰球队，但我假设这也是一种进步。但问题是，肯定还有未开发的潜力，因为在关于改变大学的750个想法中，只有不到10%的人建议拿掉某些东西。是的。我想把注意力转向组织内部发生的事情，例如，当我们围坐在桌旁进行头脑风暴会议时。
having brainstorming sessions around a table, for example. I feel like there's often a lot of pressure to add and almost no incentive to subtract. So everyone sitting around the table wants their idea implemented, polite people don't want to shoot down ideas from their colleagues. And so the net result is a pile-up of new programs, new projects, a ton of additions. Certainly, there's politeness, and then there's also just it's kind of a good decision-making shortcut to not come in and say, oh, here's something we definitely should subtract from this organization until you understand how the organization works, right?
我觉得通常有很多增加的压力，而几乎没有减法的动力。所以每个人都坐在桌旁，希望自己的想法得到实施，懂礼貌的人不想驳回同事的想法。因此，最终的结果是新项目、新计划的堆积，大量的加法。当然，有礼貌的因素，而且这也是一个很好的决策捷径，即在你不了解组织如何运作之前，不要贸然说：“哦，这绝对是我们应该从这个组织中减掉的东西”，对吧？
I mean, so it's pretty bold for somebody to say, hey, let's get rid of the ice hockey team before you understand how, you know, what they're contributing to the university, the history of the ice hockey team, and so on and so forth. To add something, you can just say, well, this would make anything better. So let's add it to our system that I don't really understand. I understand that you've also looked at how adding could even have biological roots. Tell me about the work of Stephanie Preston. Yes, Stephanie is one of my favorite researchers. She's a psychologist at the University of Michigan,
我的意思是，对于某个人来说，在了解冰球队对大学的贡献、冰球队的历史等等之前，就说“嘿，让我们解散冰球队吧”，这太鲁莽了。要添加一些东西，你只需说：“好吧，这会让任何事情变得更好。”所以让我们把它加到我并不真正理解的系统中。据我了解，你还研究了做加法甚至如何具有生物学根基。跟我讲讲斯蒂芬妮·普雷斯顿的研究。是的，斯蒂芬妮是我最喜欢的研究人员之一。她是密歇根大学的心理学家，
and she knows more than anybody about what she calls a quizzitiveness, which is how and why we get and keep things. So for example, one of my favorite studies of hers, participants are shown more than 100 different objects in random order and one at a time. And then as each object appears on the screen, participants are asked whether they would like to acquire it virtually. It's all imaginary. They know they won't actually get these things. And
她比任何人都更了解她所谓的“求知欲”，也就是我们如何以及为什么获取并保留东西。例如，她最喜欢的一项研究中，参与者被随机、单次地展示了100多种不同的物品。然后，当每个物品出现在屏幕上时，参与者被问及他们是否愿意虚拟获取它。这一切都是想象出来的。他们知道他们不会真正得到这些东西。而且
they can acquire as many or as few as they want. And the objects vary in their usefulness. So there are things like bananas and coffee mugs and extension cords, things you might pick up, others seem less useful, but people do still pick up. Like empty two liter bottles, used sticky notes, outdated newspapers. And once they have made a choice about each of these 100 objects, participants are then shown everything that they've added. So if you've acquired 70 things, you're showing all 70 things together on the screen,
他们可以根据自己的意愿获取任意多或任意少的物品。这些物品的实用性各不相同。所以有些东西像香蕉、咖啡杯和延长线，这是你可能会捡起来的东西，另一些看起来不那么有用，但人们还是会捡起来。比如空的两升瓶子、用过的便签、过时的报纸。一旦他们对这100个物品中的每一个都做出了选择，参与者就会看到他们添加的所有东西。所以如果你获取了70个东西，你就会在屏幕上同时看到这70个东西，
and then you're encouraged to subtract. Then they're challenged to whittle down their collection so that it can fit into a shopping cart on the computer screen. And finally, they're asked to make it even smaller so that it can fit into one virtual paper grocery bag. So the goal is very clear. Everything needs to fit into one grocery bag or else you don't complete the task. And you're getting real-time feedback displayed on the screen of whether you've subtracted enough
然后鼓励你做减法。接着，他们面临的挑战是削减他们的藏品，使其能够装进电脑屏幕上的购物车中。最后，他们被要求将其变得更小，以便能装进一个虚拟的纸质杂货袋里。所以目标非常明确。一切都需要装进一个杂货袋里，否则你就无法完成任务。而且你会得到实时反馈，屏幕上会显示你是否已经减掉了足够的
stuff. And a lot of participants fail to get it down to a single bag. And many don't even make it past the shopping cart. I understand there's also been research into what happens inside the brain when we engage in addition or engage in subtraction. What is that research show, Lady? One way that the neuroscientists have studies this is hooking people up to their brain imaging machines while they're acquiring things. And so food acquisition, as well as other types of acquisition, activate this same reward
东西。许多参与者未能将其减少到一个袋子。许多人甚至连购物车那一关都过不了。据我了解，还有关于当我们在进行加法或减法时，大脑内部会发生什么的科学研究。这项研究显示了什么，利迪？神经科学家研究这一点的方法之一是，在人们获取东西时，将他们连接到大脑成像机器上。因此，食物获取以及其他类型的获取，会激活大脑中的同一奖励
system in the brain. So it's this pathway connects basically the thinking and the feeling parts of our brain. And this is what makes it pleasurable to eat. And it can also be stimulated as we know by drugs like cocaine, website designs that keep us clicking and scrolling. And then for hoarders, even the used sticky notes can kind of stimulate this reward pathway.
系统。所以这条通路基本上连接了我们大脑中思考和感受的部分。这就是让人产生进食快感的原因。正如我们所知，它也可以受到诸如可卡因之类的药物、让我们不断点击和滚动的网站设计的刺激。然后对于囤积者来说，甚至用过的便签也可以刺激这种奖励通路。
So that's, and so when you do find that a specific reward system like this one is playing a role, it confirms just how deep rooted some of our tendency to add might be. So you've also conducted a whole bunch of experiments and revealed what you call subtraction neglect, our tendency to ignore the power of subtraction. And one of them was inspired by a long-running debate you've had with your wife when it comes to travel? Can you give me a concrete example of this debate in action, Liddy?
所以，当你发现这样一个特定的奖励系统在起作用时，它证实了我们倾向于做加法的某些倾向是多么根深蒂固。所以你也进行了大量实验，揭示了你所谓的“减法忽视”（subtraction neglect），即我们倾向于忽视减法力量的倾向。其中一个实验灵感来自于你和妻子在旅行时长期存在的争论？你能给我一个这个争论实际发生的具体例子吗，利迪？
Well, so yeah, we go to the outer banks sometimes, and that's the islands off of North Carolina, and so your day can look something like going to look at Kitty Hawk and see where the Wright brothers did their thing, and there's, you know, go see some sand dunes, and you can go out to eat and you could drive down and look at all the lighthouses or you could kind of just let the day come to you and you know maybe do some looking for shells on the beach and see what see what happens for lunch and you know have a less scheduled day there and so I I'm more on the prefer the latter kind of vacation. My wife, Monica, likes to pack in as many activities as possible.
嗯，是的，我们有时会去外滩（Outer Banks），那是北卡罗来纳州外海的岛屿，所以你的一天可能看起来像是去看看基蒂霍克，看看莱特兄弟成就大业的地方，有……你知道的，去看一些沙丘，然后你可以出去吃饭，开车去看所有的灯塔，或者你可以任由一天自然过去，你知道的，也许在海滩上找找贝壳，看看午餐会发生什么，在那个地方过一个计划不那么紧凑的日子。所以，我更喜欢后一种度假方式。我的妻子莫妮卡喜欢把尽可能多的活动塞进行程里。
Uh-huh. And I understand that you've actually run studies, perhaps based on this marital dispute you've been having when it comes to how people think about travel. Tell me about those experiments, lady. Well, it's not a dispute. I mean, she's right, right? But this is worse than even anything Monica would schedule. So we created this sitenery for a day spent in Washington, DC. So now we're back in the experimental world again. And over the course of 14 hours, this sitenery had participants visiting major tourist sites, like the White House, the National Cathedral, the old post office, and then have them paying their respects at the various memorials, like the Lincoln
嗯哼。据我了解，你实际上做过研究，也许就是基于你们在旅行看法上一直存在的这种婚姻争端。跟我讲讲那些实验吧，利迪。嗯，这不是争端。我是说，她是正确的，对吧？但这比莫妮卡安排的还要糟糕。所以我们为在华盛顿特区度过的一天创建了这个行程。所以现在我们又回到了实验世界。在14个小时的时间里，这个行程让参与者参观主要的旅游景点，如白宫、国家大教堂、老邮局，然后让他们在各种纪念碑（如林肯纪念碑）前致敬
and the Veterans Memorial, and then a museum visit, shopping and lunch at a five-star bistro. So just travel time between all these shops would exceed two hours, assuming optimal DC traffic, which never happens. Participants solve this original itinerary in like kind of a drag-and-drop interface on the computer screen and they could change their itinerary by rearranging adding and subtracting activities. And even with this jam packed itinerary, only one in four participants removed activities
和退伍军人纪念碑，然后参观博物馆，在五星级小酒馆购物和吃午餐。因此，所有这些商店之间的交通时间就会超过两个小时，假设华盛顿特区的交通状况达到最佳，而这从未发生过。参与者通过计算机屏幕上的拖放界面查看这个原始行程，他们可以通过重新排列、添加和减去活动来改变行程。尽管行程排得满满当当，但四分之一的参与者中只有一人从原本满满的行程中移除了活动。
from the packed original. Wow. And what did the rest do? They, they were some rearranged, but most added. They added to this itinerary? How is that even possible? It isn't. I mean, there's not time, but it was possible to kind of collect something,
哇。其他人做了什么？他们……有些人重新排列了，但大多数人进行了添加。他们给这个行程做了加法？这怎么可能？这不可能。我是说，根本没有时间，但通过收集某些东西是可能的，
you know, drag and drop another task. And it was enticing when they saw the other tasks sitting in there on the side. I think they were thinking, oh, look, that would be a fun thing to do. And it's kind of the same as the strategic planning. You think, okay, adding more good stuff is always good. And in this case, it was just gonna make the overall schedule
你知道的，拖放另一个任务。当他们看到其他任务坐在旁边时，这很诱人。我想他们在想：哦，看，那会是一件很有趣的事。这有点像战略规划。你心想：好吧，添加更多好东西总是好的。在这种情况下，它只会让整体日程
even more impossible and more crowded and less pleasant. There's another study you conducted that was inspired by a difficulty you encountered in your own writing. Tell me about the challenge that you have faced in your own writing and the study you conducted, lady. Anybody who spends time playing with words on paper on a screen has heard the advice, right?
变得更加不可能、更加拥挤、更不愉快。你还进行了另一项研究，其灵感来自于你在自己的写作中遇到的困难。跟我讲讲你在写作中面临的挑战以及你所做的研究吧，利迪。任何花时间在纸上或屏幕上玩弄文字的人都听过这个建议，对吧？
You know, strunk and white, they're the most assigned textbook on college and high school syllabi and their classic advice is omit needless words that editing is the way to make your writing more clear. And yet that's very obviously a form of subtracting, right? You're taking something that you've created and now you're taking things away from it. So we gave people a summary of an article and said, how would you make this better? And only 17% ended up subtracting words from the original. So by and large, they added to make the summaries better. And I understand the same thing applies
你知道的，斯特伦克和怀特（Strunk and White），他们是大学和高中教学大纲中最常指定的教科书，他们的经典建议是省略多余的词语，编辑是让你的写作更清晰的方法。然而这显然是一种做减法的方式，对吧？你拿走你创造的东西，然后从其中拿掉一些东西。所以我们给人们提供了一篇文章的摘要，并问：你将如何改进它？最后只有17%的人从原文中减去了字词。所以总的来说，他们为了改进摘要而做了加法。而且我理解，同样的情况也适用于
when you look at how people think about recipes, for example, how they're cooking, the same idea, addition rather than subtraction. Oh, yeah, we found this in so many contexts. I mean, people improving a five ingredient recipe, two out of 90 participants subtracted when they transformed loops of musical notes, they were more likely to add notes than to take them away.
当你看看人们如何看待食谱时，例如他们是如何做饭的，同样的道理，加法胜过减法。哦，是的，我们在这么多的语境中都发现了这一点。我的意思是，当人们改进一个五种成分的食谱时，90名参与者中只有两人做了减法；当他们转换乐音循环时，他们更有可能是添加音符而不是拿掉音符。
So this was, we found this across many different contexts. When we come back, techniques to battle the obstacles that stand in the way of subtraction. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Engineer Lidy Klaat is convinced that our world would be a better place if we engaged more often in subtraction instead of always choosing to add. The problem is there are many psychological obstacles to subtraction. There are times, however,
所以这是我们在许多不同的语境中都发现的现象。稍后回来，我们将探讨对抗阻碍减法障碍的技术。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹特姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹特姆。工程师利迪·克洛茨坚信，如果我们更经常地进行减法而不是总是选择做加法，我们的世界会变得更美好。问题是，做减法存在许多心理障碍。然而，有时
when opportunities for subtraction open up and Lidy says smart people and smart communities seize on such opportunities. Lidy, tell me the story of San Francisco's Embarcadero Freeway. Lighty, tell me the story of San Francisco's Embarcadero Freeway. Yeah, like so many other city crossing highways in the United States, the Embarcadero Freeway was built after World War II and it was made possible by federal support for highways to move the military and serve the growing number of automobiles that stretched for more than a mile along the eastern waterfront. And it blocked precious views and access to the bay. And so, you know, planners started to think,
做减法的机会会出现，利迪说，聪明人和聪明的社区抓住了这些机会。利迪，给我讲讲旧金山内河码头高速公路的故事吧。利迪，给我讲讲旧金山内河码头高速公路的故事吧。是的，就像美国的许多其他城市穿城高速公路一样，内河码头高速公路是在第二次世界大战后建造的，它是由联邦对高速公路的支持促成的，旨在运送军队并服务于不断增长的汽车数量，这些汽车沿着东部海滨绵延一英里多。它阻挡了珍贵的视野和通往海湾的通道。所以，你知道的，规划人员开始思考，
well, is this costing more than it's adding? And finally, the planning commission said, and this is in the mid 80s, we should get rid of the Embarcadero freeway. And what was the public reaction to this? Not good. But this one actually got put to a vote, and it wasn't even close. For every voter in favor of removing it, there were two who wanted to
这付出的代价是否超过了它所增加的价值？最后，规划委员会表示——这是在80年代中期——我们应该拆除内河码头高速公路。公众对此有何反应？不好。但这个提议实际上被付诸表决了，而且票数并不接近。每有一个赞成拆除的选民，就有两个想要
keep it, and whether it was for, you know, fear of traffic, fear of loss business, fear of change, voters rejected it, and the people had spoken. I mean, so the Planning Commission basically moved on and focused on other projects. So following the 1986 vote, it seemed that the possibility of tearing down the freeway and opening up the waterfront was dead. And then something happened on October 17, 1989. I'm Ted Coppel. There has been a rather strong earthquake in Northern California. So strong in fact that Ed has among other things knocked out all the power at Candlestick Park where the third game of the World Series was being played. But in the overall scheme of things, that may be the very least of things that has happened
保留它的人，无论是出于对交通的恐惧、对生意受损的恐惧、还是对改变的恐惧，选民们都否决了它，民意已经很明确了。我的意思是，规划委员会基本上继续前进并专注于其他项目。因此，在1986年的投票之后，拆除高速公路并开放海滨的可能性似乎已经破灭了。然后，在1989年10月17日发生了一件事。我是泰德·科佩尔。北加州发生了相当强烈的地震。强烈到它除其他事项外，切断了烛台公园的所有电力，世界大赛的第三场比赛当时正在那里举行。但在整体大局中，这可能是发生的事情中最微不足道的一部分
today. Let me show you a piece of video. So this was the Loma Prieta earthquake and of course the earthquake was a terrible thing, it caused a lot of damage. But it may have had one unexpected benefit. It changed how people thought about the Embarcadero Freeway. How so? Well, a number of ways.
今天。我给大家看一段视频。这是洛马普列塔大地震，当然地震是一件可怕的事情，它造成了巨大的破坏。但它可能带来了一个意想不到的好处。它改变了人们对内embarcadero高速公路的看法。怎么说呢？嗯，有很多方面。
So the earthquake killed more than 60 people and injured thousands. A lot of the deaths actually happened on a similar double-decker highway. The Cypress street viaduct in Oakland. And so people seeing this double-decker, elevated, concrete structure just over a mile in length, it looked ominously like the Embarcadero. And then it also gave people a view of what life would be like if you didn't have the
所以地震造成60多人死亡，数千人受伤。许多死亡实际上发生在一个类似的双层高速公路上。奥克兰的赛普拉斯街高架桥。因此，人们看到这个双层的、高架的、长达一英里多的混凝土结构，看起来不祥地像恩巴卡德罗。然后它还让人们看到了生活会是什么样子，如果你没有
Embarcadero, because the Embarcadero didn't collapse during the earthquake, but it was rendered unusable for a while. And so people saw that they found other ways to get around the city, and that it didn't kind of totally ruin life in San Francisco to not have the embarkadero. And then what finally came of all of this, Lighty? It was still, it wasn't like, it was by no means a unanimous choice. I mean, there's a famous Pulitzer Prize winning San Francisco Chronicle columnist and his name's Herb Kane and he's such an influential columnist. And even after
恩巴卡德罗，因为恩巴卡德罗在地震中没有倒塌，但有一段时间无法使用。所以人们看到他们找到了其他绕过城市的方式，而且没有恩巴卡德罗并没有完全毁掉旧金山的生活。那么这一切的最终结果是什么，莱蒂？这仍然不是，这绝不是一个一致的选择。我的意思是，有一位著名的普利策奖得主《旧金山纪事报》专栏作家，他的名字叫赫布·凯恩，他是一位非常有影响力的专栏作家。甚至在
the earthquake, as people brought this discussion back up, he has this great quote, once again, there's serious talk about tearing down the Embarcadero Freeway and even worse idea than building it. And so there was still resistance. But eventually the freeway came down. And when it was removed, they got the water front back. They saw an increase in housing, increase in jobs. It didn't cause traffic nightmare. Trips were rerouted. And if you've ever visited there,
地震发生后，当人们重新提起这个讨论时，他有一句很棒的名言，再次有人认真讨论拆除恩巴卡德罗高速公路，这甚至比修建它还要糟糕的想法。所以仍然有阻力。但最终高速公路被拆除了。当它被移除时，他们找回了海滨。他们看到住房增加，工作岗位增加。它没有造成交通噩梦。行程被重新路线。如果你曾经去过那里，
it's one of the most visited places in the world. And it's obvious why it shouldn't be covered with a freeway. So it took about 10 years, but by 2000, visited places in the world and it's obvious why it shouldn't be covered with the freeways. So it took about 10 years, but by 2000, kind of the 10-year anniversary of the demolition, the Chronicle was then reporting that it was hard to find anyone who thinks ripping down the freeway was a bad idea. So we've had a crisis of our own the last couple of years. It have forced a lot of us to think about what we do, where we work,
它是世界上游客最多的地方之一。很明显为什么它不应该被高速公路覆盖。所以这花了大约10年时间，但在2000年，世界游客访问量最大的地方，很明显为什么它不应该被高速公路覆盖。所以这花了大约10年时间，但在2000年，也就是拆除十周年之际，《纪事报》随后报道说，很难找到任何人认为拆除高速公路是个坏主意。所以过去几年我们经历了我们自己的危机。这迫使我们很多人思考我们做什么，我们在哪里工作，
how we work, how might the COVID-19 pandemic serve as a potential driver of subtraction, Lady? Yeah, I mean, I think at horrific cost, it's given us this singular chance for change and forced us to subtract in ways that we never would have managed on our own. And certainly, I don't advocate subtracting family visits and friendly hugs, but we've also had to get rid of things that I don't mind if they don't come back, things like buffets and commutes and evictions and even carbon emissions. So I think that the crises interrupts this normal flow of things and shows us what a world with some of these subtractions might look like.
我们如何工作，COVID-19大流行如何成为潜在的减法驱动力，莱蒂？是的，我的意思是，我认为以可怕的代价，它给了我们这个独特的改变机会，迫使我们以我们自己永远无法做到的方式进行减法。当然，我不主张减少家庭访问和友好的拥抱，但我们也必须摆脱那些即使不回来我也无所谓的事情，比如自助餐、通勤、驱逐甚至碳排放。所以我认为危机打断了事物的正常流动，向我们展示了一个带有这些减法特征的世界会是什么样子。
You know, isn't it interesting that so often we actually need the external push before we can, before we see the value and subtraction? You know, we've talked about earthquakes, we've talked about a pandemic. I mean, you can think of a forest fire the same way. It's obviously not a good thing when you have a forest fire, but, you know, the removal of all growth might be helpful for new growth
你知道，很有趣的是，在看到减法的价值之前，我们往往需要外部的推动？你知道，我们讨论过地震，我们讨论过大流行。我的意思是，你可以用同样的方式看待森林大火。发生森林大火显然不是一件好事，但是，你知道，清除所有生长物可能有助于新的生长
to happen in a forest. When I'm thinking about the marketplace, for example, businesses go out of business. Stores go out of business because they kind of track customers or they're selling stuff that people no longer want. And of course, it's painful if you happen to be the store owner whose business is going bankrupt. But the net effect of this is that it gives another business
在森林中发生。例如，当我考虑市场时，企业倒闭了。商店倒闭是因为它们追踪客户或者它们出售人们不再想要的东西。当然，如果你恰好是那个濒临破产的店主，这会很痛苦。但这样做的净效应是它给另一家企业
a chance to sort of spring up. But in each of these cases, it's interesting that we almost need the external force in order to, for us to see the value of subtraction. It's almost, it's so emotionally difficult for us to do the subtraction ourselves that we need almost an external executioner to come in and do the hard stuff for us. Yeah, emotionally and cognitively difficult.
一个萌芽的机会。但在每一种情况下，有趣的是，我们几乎需要外部力量，才能让我们看到减法的价值。这几乎对我们来说在情感上太难了，以至于我们需要几乎一个外部的行刑者进来为我们做艰难的事情。是的，在情感上和认知上都很困难。
And even if you look at evolution as a metaphor, the way that it works is through adaptation and then selection. So adaptation is an ad, and then the selection is a a subtraction and they're working hand in hand. And I think another fundamental disadvantage that's coming into play here is that we don't get as many reminders of subtraction, right? Because when something is added, there it is right in front of you as evidence that this adding this thing was a way to make change. If something was subtracted in the rare cases that we do it and follow through with it, it's by definition gone. So as we walk around in the world, we don't have these external
即使你把演化看作一个隐喻，它工作的方式也是通过适应然后选择。所以适应是一个加法，然后选择是一个减法，它们携手合作。我认为这里发挥作用的另一个根本劣势是，我们没有得到那么多的减法提醒，对吧？因为当添加了某事时，它就在你面前作为证据，证明添加这个东西是做出改变的一种方式。如果减去了某事，在极少数情况下我们这样做并坚持到底，它根据定义就消失了。所以当我们在世界各地行走时，我们没有这些外部的
reminders that, hey, here's this subtraction. It's also a good way to make things better. The things we subtract are often invisible. We don't notice them or we quickly become used to their absence. And so we fail to appreciate how these innovations, like Anna Kaiklan's building blocks, are affecting our lives. But sometimes inventors can find clever workarounds to this obstacle. a workaround to this obstacle. Back in the 1970s, an aerospace engineer named Marion Rudy came up with the idea of using air to provide cushioning and running shoes. It was a classic moment where less added up to more. But there was a problem.
提醒，嘿，这里是这个减法。这也是让事情变得更好的好方法。我们减去的东西往往是隐形的。我们没有注意到它们，或者我们很快就习惯了它们的缺席。因此，我们没有意识到这些创新（如安娜·凯克兰的积木）是如何影响我们的生活的。但有时发明者可以找到巧妙的变通方法来克服这个障碍。克服这个障碍的变通方法。早在20世纪70年代，一位名叫马里恩·鲁迪的航空航天工程师想出了用空气在跑鞋中提供缓冲的想法。这是一个经典的时刻，减法带来了加法。但有一个问题。
You couldn't actually see this innovation in action. It was inside the shoes. Marion Rudi kept bringing the idea to shoe companies and they kept turning him down. He finally got to Nike, which at the time was kind of this boutique outfit that just served elite runners. And as the story goes, in Nike lore, Phil Knight took him out for a run, liked what he felt,
你实际上看不到这种创新在起作用。它在鞋子里面。马里恩·鲁迪不断将这个想法带给鞋类公司，而他们不断拒绝他。他终于找到了耐克，当时耐克有点像一个只服务于精英跑者的精品品牌。正如故事所说，在耐克传说中，菲尔·奈特带他去跑步，喜欢他所感受到的，
and then Error went into the Nike shoes. But for even after the air was in the shoes, nobody could see it. And so, but the Nike really started to take off, they had this kind of seminal shoe, the Air Max one. And those shoes were one of the first models that actually displayed the air.
然后空气进入了耐克鞋。但即使空气进入鞋子后，也没有人能看到它。所以，但耐克真正开始起飞时，他们有这种标志性的鞋子，Air Max one。这些鞋子是第一批真正展示空气的模型之一。
So they have the little window on the side so you could see, hey, in fact, there's air in here. And that made the subtraction noticeable. And it was something that made Nike shoes different from any other kind of shoe and kind of helped launch them on the path that took them to where they are today. Of course, there's a guy named Michael Jordan who helped you. So we've looked at how external crises can sometimes be a driver of subtraction and how, you know, increasing the noticeability of subtraction, the value of subtraction can help us, can help us embrace subtraction. You've also thought about other systems in some ways
所以在侧面有一个小窗口，你可以看到，嘿，事实上，这里有空气。这使得减法变得引人注目。这让耐克的鞋子与任何其他类型的鞋子都不同，并帮助开启了他们走向今天的道路。当然，有一个叫迈克尔·乔丹的人帮助了你。所以我们研究了外部危机有时如何成为减法的驱动力，以及如何，你知道，提高减法的显眼性，减法的价值可以帮助我们，可以帮助我们拥抱减法。你还考虑了在某些方面的其他系统
that can incentivize people to focus on subtraction. Tell me about your stop doing list, lady. A stop doing list is essentially the same as a to do list, except for your thinking of things that you're not going to do anymore. And what I, how I use it is whenever I do my to do's, which I try to do on a weekly basis, I also force myself to come up
可以激励人们专注于减法。告诉我你的停止做清单，莱蒂。停止做清单本质上和待办事项清单相同，除了你考虑的是你将不再做的事情。而我，我是如何使用它的，每当我做我的待办事项时，我尽量每周做一次，我也强迫自己提出
with a equivalent number of stop-doings, which kind of makes sense, right? If you're gonna add new stuff to your day and assuming you're already at capacity, you need to also figure out what you're going to take away. Are there any specific things on your stop-doing list that you have? I'm curious when, in terms of your stop
等量的停止做事项，这在某种程度上是有道理的，对吧？如果你要在一天中添加新东西，假设你已经满负荷了，你还需要弄清楚你要拿掉什么。你的停止做清单上有什么具体的事情吗？我很想知道，就你的停止
doing list, what are the things that you put on? One that's been really helpful for me is it's basically a stop editing and this is I read a lot of my students writing and it can be really tempting to just go through and make all of the changes that I would want to make but of course that's not really helpful to them and so I like I'll set a limit, I'll say, okay, give this student the 10 most important comments for this piece of writing. And it works really well, I mean, it saves me time one, but it also kind of rewards students who do more, right? So if the student gives you a really polished piece of writing,
做清单而言，你放上了什么东西？对我真的很有帮助的一个是它基本上是一个停止编辑，我读了很多学生的写作，直接通读并做出我想做的所有修改可能会非常诱人，但当然这对他们没有真正的帮助，所以我喜欢，我会设定一个限制，我会说，好吧，给这个学生的这篇写作提供10个最重要的评论。这真的很管用，我的意思是，一方面它为我节省了时间，但它也奖励了做更多事情的学生，对吧？所以如果学生给你一篇打磨得很好的写作，
I still force myself to come up with 10 ways to make it better, whereas if somebody doesn't put as much time in and gives you this really rough first draft, I don't spend all my time getting that to the same place that the other piece of writing is. Another example is just meetings. Meetings are the classic thing where I am providing some marginal value by attending a meeting or by calling a meeting, but not considering what could be done in that time. So I think oftentimes my stop-doings are directed at meetings that I'm attending, but also the ones that I'm calling and asking other people to attend for me.
我仍然强迫自己想出10种方法让它变得更好，而如果有人没有投入那么多时间，给你这个非常粗糙的初稿，我就不会花所有的时间把那个弄到和其他写作一样的地方。另一个例子就是会议。会议是典型的例子，我通过参加会议或召开会议来提供一些边际价值，但没有考虑在那段时间里可以做什么。所以我认为很多时候我的停止做事项针对的是我正在参加的会议，但也包括我召开并要求其他人为我参加的会议。
Can you talk a moment about the role of subtraction in public policy? You know, when we think about legislators, for example, we think about legislators as people who make laws. Whereas you might argue that a crucial part of what legislators ought to be doing is pruning back laws that might no longer be useful. Yeah, I did some digging into how much laws have grown over time. And by some measures, they've grown even faster than our economy. So it's just like all these things have this adding trend
你能谈谈减法在公共政策中的作用吗？你知道，当我们想到立法者时，例如，我们认为立法者是制定法律的人。而你可能会认为，立法者应该做的一个关键部分是修剪掉可能不再有用的法律。是的，我深入研究了法律随时间增长了多少。根据某些衡量标准，它们的增长速度甚至比我们的经济还要快。所以就像所有这些东西都有这种添加的趋势一样
and laws are no exception. And it's the same as the building of civilization. When you don't have roads, it makes sense to add them. And once you've kind of been adding roads for a while, there are more opportunities to take them away to reveal pristine water. And so the laws, we've kind of accumulated, accumulated, accumulated, and we're left with a bunch that are redundant.
法律也不例外。这与文明的建设是一样的。当你没有道路时，添加它们是有意义的。一旦你添加了一段时间的道路，就有更多的机会把它们移走以展现清澈的水。所以法律，我们一直在积累，积累，积累，最后留下了一堆多余的法律。
And so some places have actually required legislators to, when they come with a new law, also come with two that are on the books that they want to get rid of. And that kind of rule can be really helpful, I mean it's saying, look, you're a competent legislator if you do this. Lighty has been struck by the fact that subtraction can play a surprisingly powerful role in medicine. Doctors and nurses often have so much going on that simplifying rules and reducing complexity can actually improve patient outcomes.
因此，有些地方实际上要求立法者，当他们提出新法律时，也要提出他们想要摆脱的账面上的两条法律。这种规则真的很有帮助，我的意思是它在说，看，如果你这样做，你就是一个称职的立法者。莱蒂对减法在医学中可以发挥令人惊讶的强大作用印象深刻。医生和护士经常有太多的事情要做，简化规则和减少复杂性实际上可以改善患者的治疗结果。
Yeah, my sister is a medical doctor and she was actually taught by this guy, Peter Pranovost, and what Pranovost was interested in was improving the practice of inserting central line catheters. So these are those thin plastic tubes that are used to draw blood or administer fluids and medication. Catheters are ubiquitous in American hospitals, and they're also one of the most common sources of infection. And it's not a sexy topic, certainly, but these infections were actually causing about 30,000 deaths each year in the United States, roughly as many as car accidents. And it's a complicated process.
是的，我姐姐是一名医学博士，她实际上是跟这个人彼得·普拉诺沃斯特学习的，而普拉诺沃斯特感兴趣的是改进插入中心静脉导管的做法。所以这些是用于抽血或输液和药物的细塑料管。导管在美式医院中无处不在，它们也是感染最常见的来源之一。这当然不是一个性感的课题，但这些 infections 实际上每年在美国造成约30,000人死亡，大致相当于车祸造成的死亡人数。这是一个复杂的过程。
There are dozens of steps requiring thought, enjudgment, and skill, and it's different based on the person. If you've got a 10-year-old who's dehydrated, it's a different process than inserting one on a concussed offensive lineman, for example. But to prevent the infections, Pronovost and his team considered all of this complexity, but then they proposed a very simple recipe. They gave a checklist, and it's that medical professionals would wash their hands with soap, clean the patient's skin with antiseptic, put sterile drapes over the entire patient, wear a sterile mask hat, gown and gloves, and put a sterile dressing over the catheter site. And those very simple steps have brought striking results. It's almost entirely eradicated catheter
有几十个步骤需要思考、判断和技能，并且根据个人的不同而有所不同。例如，如果你有一个脱水的10岁孩子，这与在脑震荡的进攻线卫身上插入导管的过程是不同的。但为了预防感染，普拉诺沃斯特和他的团队考虑了所有这些复杂性，然后他们提出了一个非常简单的方案。他们给出了一个清单，医疗专业人员会用肥皂洗手，用防腐剂清洁患者的皮肤，在整个患者身上盖上无菌铺巾，戴上无菌口罩帽子、长袍和手套，并在导管部位盖上无菌敷料。这些非常简单的步骤带来了惊人的结果。它几乎完全消除了导管
infections and it saved thousands of lives. We've talked at some length about how edition is psychologically pleasurable and subtraction is often psychologically painful. One of your really interesting insights is that we should all try to reframe losses, subtractions as additions. And there's an author you like who preaches this message. Here's the clip of her. The important things about tidying is not choosing things to discard, but choosing things to keep. So, how do you choose what to keep? If the item sparks you, I keep it. If it does not, get rid of it.
感染，并挽救了数千人的生命。我们已经相当详细地讨论了加法在心理上是令人愉快的，而减法在心理上往往是痛苦的。你真正有趣的见解之一是，我们都应该尝试将损失、减法重新定义为加法。有一位你喜欢的作家宣扬这个信息。这里是她的剪辑。整理的重要东西不是选择要丢弃的东西，而是选择要保留的东西。那么，你如何选择要保留的东西呢？如果这个物品能激发你的灵感，我留着它。如果没有，就把它扔掉。
I take it you're a fan of the Taidi In Guru, Murikondo. Yeah, a reluctant fan. I mean, as a professor, I felt like, oh, I can't be a condo Acolyte, but talking about our research, people would keep bringing her up So I said I got a figure out what she's writing about and you know Of course her tone and observations advice are very spiritual But through trial and error in this her specific context that tid, she's derived some tips that are pretty scientifically
我想你是整理大师近藤麻理惠的粉丝。是的，一个勉强的粉丝。我的意思是，作为一名教授，我觉得，哦，我不能成为近藤的信徒，但谈到我们的研究时，人们会不断提起她，所以我说我得弄清楚她在写什么，你知道，当然她的语气和观察建议非常精神，但通过试验和错误在这个她的特定背景下，整理，她得出了一些非常科学的
sound. For example, her core message is sparking joy. Default home organization advice is like, get rid of the stuff you don't want that doesn't fit. And she flipped it around. She said, keep what sparks joy and get rid of everything else. And so she's kind of steering us around Mausah version there knowingly or not because she's focusing us on this, you know, this future vision of the tidy space and and sure it's a little painful to get rid of these individual things, but you're just thinking of them as one component that's going to improve the overall situation. I understand you've also looked at artists, writers, musicians, painters, who've also thought deeply
合理的建议。例如，她的核心信息是激发快乐。默认的家庭组织建议是，摆脱你不想要的、不适合的东西。而她把它颠倒了过来。她说，保留激发快乐的东西，把其他一切都扔掉。所以她不知情地引导我们避开损失厌恶，因为她让我们专注于这个，你知道，整理空间的未来愿景，当然摆脱这些单独的东西有点痛苦，但你只是把它们当作将改善整体情况的一个组成部分。据我所知，你还研究了艺术家、作家、音乐家、画家，他们也深入思考过
about subtraction. What have you found, lady? I mean, it's hard to find an expert who doesn't have some counterintuitive, seemingly counterintuitive advice on how to subtract, right? So Picasso defining art is the elimination of the unnecessary, and then you've got the little princes author saying, perfection's achieved, not when there's nothing more to add,
关于减法。你发现了什么，莱蒂？我的意思是，很难找到一个专家没有一些关于如何做减法的反直觉的、看似反直觉的建议，对吧？所以毕加索将艺术定义为消除不必要的东西，然后小王子的作者说，完美的实现不是当没有更多东西可以添加时，
but when there's nothing left to take away. We talked about strung and white, amidst needless words. This goes way back. I mean, you've got William Ovocum of Ovocum's razor fame, and his quote is, it's in vain to do with more what can be done with less. And then a quote that gets attributed to Lao Tzu, to attain knowledge, add things every day, to attain wisdom, subtract things every day. And that's two and a half millennia back.
而是当没有什么可拿走的时候。我们谈论了斯特伦和怀特，在不必要的词语中间。这可以追溯到很久以前。我的意思是，你有因奥卡姆剃刀闻名的威廉·奥卡姆，他的名言是，能用较少完成的事，用较多去做是徒劳的。然后有一句归于老子的名言，为学日益，为道日损。那已经是两个半 millennia 以前了。
And I think I learned a ton from these new and old profits of subtraction, but the main takeaway is that they're the exceptions proving the rule, right? They're advice and doers because we are still neglecting subtraction. I want to play on excerpt from a song from an artist you admire. There's a darkness on the edge of town. There's a darkness on the edge of town. Lady, tell me about Bruce Springsteen's celebrated album, Darkness on the Edge of Town. He's my favorite musician and I think I love darkness on the edge of town as an example of persistent subtraction. So there are 10 songs on the album, the one you just played,
我想我从这些新的和旧的减法先知那里学到了很多，但主要的收获是他们是证明规则的例外，对吧？他们的建议是做，因为我们仍然在忽视减法。我想播放你欣赏的一位艺术家的歌曲片段。城镇边缘有一片黑暗。城镇边缘有一片黑暗。莱蒂，跟我讲讲布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀著名的专辑《城镇边缘的黑暗》。他是我最喜欢的音乐家，我认为我喜欢《城镇边缘的黑暗》作为持续减法的例子。所以专辑里有10首歌，你刚刚播放的那首，
darkness on the edge of town being the title track, but he recorded more than 50 songs during this time just to get those 10. And these are not bad songs that he cut but some of the ones he cut became hits instantly for other artists so Patty Smith's because the night that got to number 13 on the charts he gave a song Gary U.S. Bond's This Little Girl that hit number 11 on the charts the pointer sisters fire which hit number two on the charts that's a Bruce Springsteen song and a thing that he didn't think was good enough to go on darkness on the edge of town and now we a Bruce Springsteen song. And a thing that he didn't think was good enough to go on darkness on the edge of town. And now we know Bruce Springsteen
《城镇边缘的黑暗》是主打歌，但他在这个时候录制了50多首歌曲，只为了选出这10首。这些不是他砍掉的烂歌，但他砍掉的一些歌曲立即成为其他艺术家的热门歌曲，比如帕蒂·史密斯的《因为夜晚》在排行榜上排名第13位，他把一首歌曲给了加里·U.S.邦斯的《这个小女孩》在排行榜上排名第11位，指针姐妹的《火》在排行榜上排名第2位，那是布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的歌，而他认为不够好而没有放进《城镇边缘的黑暗》中的东西。现在我们知道了布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀
is this incredibly successful musician, but the audacity at the time, he had yet to have a top 20 single of his own, and he gave away three singles off that that became top 20 hits for other artists. And what do you think he was after doing this kind of extreme culling? He has a great description of it in his autobiography, Born to Run, which is just an amazing autobiography.
是一位非常成功的音乐家，但在当时却很大胆，他还没有拥有属于自己的前20名单曲，他送出了那张专辑里的三首单曲，成为了其他艺术家的前20名热门歌曲。你认为他进行这种极端的精简是为了追求什么？他在自传《生而奔跑》中对此进行了很好的描述，那是一本令人惊叹的自传。
He talks about this album as his samurai record, all stripped down for fighting, and those are his exact words. So he was going for this really stripped down aesthetic than he had had on any of his previous albums and that he thought would kind of revolutionize the way music was heard. I understand that one of these songs has a special meaning for you and your son.
他把这张专辑称为他的武士唱片，为了战斗而剥离一切，这些是他的原话。所以他追求的是一种比他以往任何专辑都更剥离的美学，他认为这将彻底改变音乐被听到方式。我听说这些歌中的一首对你和你的儿子有特殊的意义。
Yes, my absolute favorite song from that album will always be racing in the street. And that's's been that was Ezra's Valla Bifur as long as he needed them. He doesn't eat them anymore and it's a very stripped-down song. The first line of it is I got a 69 Chevy with a 396 and that's illustrative of the sparse lyrics that are present all the way across, starting from the edge of town. And this is really a transformation for Springsteen because the opening line to the first song
是的，我绝对最喜欢的那张专辑里的歌永远是《街头赛车》。那是埃夫拉的巴利福，只要他需要的话。他不再需要它了，这是一首非常剥离的歌。它的第一行是“我有一辆69年的雪佛兰，带着396”，这说明了贯穿始终的稀疏歌词，从城镇边缘开始。这对斯普林斯汀来说确实是一个转变，因为第一首歌的开场白
on his debut album, Greetings from Edgesbury Park, it's the song blinded by the light, which here's the opening line. Madman drummers, bummers, and Indians in the summer with a teenage diplomat. So he's perfectly capable of this meandering, Dylan-esque pros. And now he's going to racing in the street. I got a 69 Chevy with a 396. Tonight, tonight, the strip's just right. I wanna blowom off in my first team.
在他的首张专辑《来自阿斯伯里帕克的问候》中，那是歌曲《被光盲蔽》，这是开场白。疯子鼓手、流浪汉和夏天的印第安人带着一个十几岁的外交官。所以他完全有能力写这种蜿蜒的、鲍勃·迪伦式的散文。现在他要唱《街头赛车》了。我有一辆69年的雪佛兰，带着396。今晚，今晚，地带刚刚好。我想在我的第一支球队里炸毁。
Lighty Cloth is the professor of engineering at the University of Virginia. He's the author of Subtract, the untapped power of less. Lighty, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. We take all the action we can make, and we cover all of Northeastern. When the strip sits down, we run out. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ani Murphy-Paul, Laura Quarelle,
莱蒂·克罗斯是弗吉尼亚大学的工程学教授。她是《减法：较少的未开发力量》的作者。莱蒂，谢谢你今天加入我的《隐形大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。我们采取我们能采取的一切行动，我们覆盖了东北部的所有地方。当带子坐下来时，我们就跑出去了。《隐形大脑》由隐形大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保尔、劳拉·夸雷勒、
Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Today, for our unsung hero segment, we bring you a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. A few years ago, Laquista Arena's six-year-old son Jackson was diagnosed with autism. This wasn't a surprise. Ever since he was a baby, she had noticed he was overly sensitive to everyday things. Textures in his clothes, light touches, loud sounds. Haircuts were the worst. He gets so anxious that he'd start kicking and screaming.
克里斯滕·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐形大脑》的执行主编。今天，在我们的无名英雄环节，我们为您带来来自我们姐妹播客《我的无名英雄》的一个故事。几年前，拉奎斯塔·阿里纳六岁的儿子杰克逊被诊断出患有自闭症。这并不奇怪。自从他还是个婴儿以来，她就注意到他对日常事情过于敏感。衣服的质地、轻触、巨大的声音。理发是最糟糕的。他变得如此焦虑，以至于开始踢打和尖叫。
It was really hard for Laquista to watch, so she decided to stop taking him. This is so traumatic for my son. Why am I continuing to put him through this? And so we went almost two years with no haircuts, people making comments. You need to get his hair cut. Why your hair looks like, you know, people just say all kind of rude things.
对拉奎斯塔来说，看着这一幕真的很艰难，所以她决定不再带他去。这对我的儿子来说太痛苦了。为什么我要继续让他经历这一切？所以我们几乎有两年没有理发，人们发表评论。你需要给他理发。为什么你的头发看起来像，你知道，人们只是说各种粗鲁的话。
Eventually, LaQuista found a barber named Rhee. For the past few years, Rhee has been able to take things slow with Jackson and learn how to stave off his meltdowns. Until one day, in early 2022, when things went wrong. We were running late. We got caught in traffic. He left his headphones. until one day in early 2022, when things went wrong. We were running late, we got caught in traffic, he left his headphones, we hadn't had lunch, it was just like a series of unfortunate events.
最终，拉奎斯塔找到了一位名叫蕾的理发师。在过去的几年里，蕾能够慢慢地对待杰克逊，并学习如何阻止他的情绪崩溃。直到2002年初的一天，事情出了问题。我们迟到了。我们遇到了交通堵塞。他落下了他的耳机，直到2002年初的一天，事情出了问题。我们迟到了，我们遇到了交通堵塞，他落下了他的耳机，我们还没有吃午饭，这就像是一系列不幸的事件。
And he's like, no, I don't wanna go. Like come on Jackson, stop playing. I got things to do, I'm like hungry myself. Like we usually, I have to say it like three times and this time he refused to get in the seat and he started running around the shop and read saying come on Jackson man you know you my man like she's trying to talk to her she tried to put the cape on him and he just had a fit and she was like come look in the mirror I'm gonna I'm gonna show you what I'm doing and he just had a fit. And she was like, come look in the mirror. I'm gonna show you what I'm doing. And he looked, but he still wasn't having it.
他说，不，我不想去。就像来吧杰克逊，别玩了。我有很多事情要做，我自己也很饿。就像我们通常那样，我不得不说三遍，而这次他拒绝上座，他开始在店里跑来跑去，蕾说来吧杰克逊，你知道你是我的男人，就像她试图和她说话一样，她试图把斗篷戴在他身上，而他只是发脾气。她说，来照镜子。我要给你展示我在做什么，而他只是发脾气。她说，来照镜子。我要给你展示我在做什么。他看了，但仍然不接受。
And I was like, come on Jackson, I'm getting frustrated. And she was like, no, I got it. And so I just sat on the couch and I'm like, she's not gonna be able to cut his hair. I'm gonna give it five minutes. We're gonna go get something eaten, go home. Well, next thing you know, I'm looking and she's like cutting his hair, he's standing up and I'm like, wait, she's playing a game with him.
我当时想，来吧杰克逊，我越来越沮丧。她说，不，我搞定了。所以我只是坐在沙发上，我想，她不可能剪他的头发。我给它五分钟。我们要去吃点东西，然后回家。好吧，接下来你知道的，我看着，她就像在剪他的头发，他站着，我想，等等，她在跟他玩游戏。
She would shave his hair, the hair would fall, he would wipe it off. And then they would run to a different spot because he doesn't like the hair to get on him is like a whole thing. So it was a good distraction for him and she was able to kind of cut his hair. When they got finished, he was so happy. And he said, well, can we go back tomorrow and play the game?
她会剃他的头发，头发会掉下来，他会把它擦掉。然后他们会跑到不同的地方，因为他不喜欢头发弄到他身上，这是一整套动作。所以这对他是很好的分散注意力，她能够剪他的头发。当他们完成时，他是如此高兴。他说，我们明天能回去玩游戏吗？
I was like, I don't know about tomorrow, but we'll be back in a couple of weeks. Jackson and Reed, they have their own special relationship and I think most importantly he trusts her, he will not let anyone else touch his hair and that just goes to show like how she nurtured that relationship. This has been a really tough year for Jackson. The last couple years have been really challenging from starting pre-K and then now transitioning
我当时想，我不知道明天怎么样，但我们几周后会回来。杰克逊和蕾，他们有他们自己特殊的 relazione，我认为最重要的是他信任她，他不让任何人碰他的头发，这正好说明了她是多么细心地呵护这段关系。对杰克逊来说，这是非常艰难的一年。过去几年真的很有挑战性，从开始上学前班，然后现在过渡
to kindergarten and then a new school. So when Re was able to do this and just to accommodate him, it meant the absolute world for me to be able to trust her and be like, okay, I know she's going to take care of my son and make sure he's looking the best like you can't ask for anything more than that. I just want to tell Rhea that we love you, you are part of our family now and you'll never fully understand how much this meant for me as a mom. Laquistar Arena Laquistar took a video of Rida Day, calming Jackson down with the haircut in game and posted it on social media.
到幼儿园，然后是一所新学校。所以当蕾能够做到这一点并只是为了适应他时，能够信任她对我来说意味着绝对的世界，就像，好吧，我知道她会照顾我的儿子，确保他看起来最好，你不能要求比这更好的了。我只想告诉蕾，我们爱你，你现在是我们家族的一部分，你永远不会完全理解这对作为一个妈妈的我意味着什么。拉奎斯塔·阿里纳拉奎斯塔拍下了蕾当天的视频，用理发游戏让杰克逊平静下来，并把它发到了社交媒体上。
That clip now has millions of views. If you enjoyed today's conversation about how to innovate through subtraction, please be sure to share it with a few friends. Another way to help the show is through financial contributions to our work. You can make a donation in any amount at support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantım. Siyusi sün. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那个片段现在有数百万的浏览量。如果你喜欢今天关于如何通过减法进行创新的对话，请务必与几位朋友分享。帮助节目的另一种方式是通过对我们工作的资金贡献。你可以在 support.hiddenbrain.org 捐赠任何金额。再次，那是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹蒂姆。下次见。这个剧集还没有评论。点击抄本中的任何句子来发表评论。